bonjour je suis sourde
et je m'appelle i s ab eux elle elle
veut il appelle mon signe
voici
vous allez bien moi ça va
il fait beau temps
soleil brille
j'ai envie d'aller me promener
un entendant tient là on va voir comment
il s'y prend pour naples et moi qui fit
sourde
madame
o madame
mademoiselle
ah
c'est pas bon mais je t'ai une boulette
non c'est absolument pas respectueux de
moi qui suis sur deux
salles d'apparat on lui donne une
deuxième chance on va voir
voilà ça c'est bien ma plaie de cette
manière là assez respectueux voilà en
tant que personnes sourdes
bonjour
ça va
ça bah
moi je suis très content de vous
rencontrer
oui il est content de me rencontrer
une personne sur deux bons
on va le laisser un voilà il est content
de me rencontrer moi je suis aussi
content on rencontre une personne
entendante
pour qu'ils se calment quand même
à bientôt au revoir
je suis sourde
les entendants
bonjour
ça va
il
il fait beau
comptant
rencontrer
à bientôt
on revoit